It is 12:13.
And we'll call this meeting to order of the— What day is it?
I'm not saying. It was
noticed for yesterday.
It's, it's August 18th, as far as I'm concerned, at 12:13,
and we'll start our Redevelopment Agency board meeting.
And I'll officially call this meeting to order.
The first item of business is the minutes from June
16th regarding the Regulatory Development Agency board meeting.
Is there any questions on that one, or I'll take a motion if there's not.
Chair, I move that the board
approves minutes. Second. Okay, we have
a motion by Uh, board member Clark
and a second by board member Whiting, and we'll start the vote with
board member Huish. Yes. And board member Clark? Yes.
And Wright? Yes. Whiting? Yes. Wood? Yes. Okay,
that passes. Now to the first item resolution,
and this is a public hearing resolution of Redevelopment Agency of
Eagle Mountain City adopting the official project area for the Mid-Valley
Community Reinvestment Project area. It's the exact same thing we just went
through. Um, any questions? Do we need anything
on this? If not, I'm open to a motion. Oh, no, no, no, I got
a public hearing. Sorry. Thank you. Um, at 12:15,
I will open the public hearing and ask Lacey.
Nobody wants to speak on that. Better not. Is anyone here that wants to
speak on this item? Seeing no one, uh,
we'll close the public hearing at 12:15,
bring it back to the council— or board.
Sorry, you're right.
Motion? Yeah. Chair, I,
uh, I, I move that the board approve a resolution of the Redevelopment
Agency of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, adopting the official project area plan for the Mid-Valley
Community Reinvestment Project area.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Board Member
Whiting, a second by Board Member Clark, and we'll start the vote with Board Member
Clark. Yes. Board Member Wright. Yes. Board Member Whiting. Yep. Board Member Wood.
Yeah. And Board Member Hewish. Yes. Uh, 3B is also
public hearing, resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City adopting
official project area for the Mid-Valley Reinvestment Project area.
Uh, it is a public hearing. Do we need to answer any questions?
Seeing none, I will officially open the public hearing at 12:16.
Ask Lacey if there is anyone, and there is not.
Is there anyone here that would like to speak on this item? Seeing no one,
I will close the public hearing at 12:16.
Yes, and bring it back to the council.
Chair, I, uh, moved— board, board chair, I, I moved that
the board approve a resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain, City of Utah,
adopting the official project area budget. For the Mid Valley Community
Reinvestment Project area. 2nd. Okay, we have a motion
by Board Member Whiting, a 2nd by Board Member Wright, and we'll start the vote
with Board Member Wright. Yes. Board Member Whiting. Yes. Board Member Wood.
Yes. Board Member Hewish. Yes. And Board Member Clark. Yes.
Okay, the next one's item 4A, a resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of
Eagle Mountain City approving the interlocal cooperation agreement between Eagle Mountain and the
agency and Eagle Mountain City for the collection and remittance of an incremental
sales tax. In the packet, this one's wrong. This is the same
as the other one. Sales tax is, uh, it is
not a public hearing. So,
if there are no questions, I remain open for motions.
Chair, I move that the board approve a resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of
Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving an interlocal cooperation agreement between the Eagle Mountain
Redevelopment Agency and Eagle Mountain City for the collection or remittance of incremental
sales tax collected from property within the Mid Valley Community Reinvestment Project
area. Okay, we have a motion by board member Whiting, a second by
board member Wright, and we'll start the vote here with board member Whiting. Yes.
Board member Wood. No. Board member Hughes. Yes. Board member
Clark. Yes. Board member Wright. Yes. Okay, and I'm assuming the same thing,
so we'll move on to, uh, 4B, resolution of the Redevelopment
Agency of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving the Mid-Valley CRA participation agreement
between the agency and the city. So,
Not a public hearing. Any questions?
Any motions? Board chair, I move that
the board approve a resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City, Utah,
approving the Mid-Valley CRA participation agreement between the Redevelopment Agency
of Eagle Mountain City, Eagle Mountain City, and Tara Smith's
Eagle Mountain LLC. Second. Okay, we have a
motion by board member Whiting, a second by board member Clark. We'll start with board
member Wood. No. Board member Hughes. Yes. Board Member
Clark? Yes. Board Member Wright? Yes. And Board Member Whiting? Yes.
Okay, that is 4-1. And, uh, motion to adjourn. You win.
Second. Okay, so I've got Council— uh, Board Member
Whiting and Board Member Clark. Yep. And all in favor? Aye.
Okay, thank you. Appreciate you guys' work. I,
I, um, just— hey, hey.
Just real quick, and it might be too late. We had left some items on
the closed session. I think the consensus is that we're going to
punt. Is that okay?
Yes. I don't know if it was time sensitive. I don't
even see Abby. Abby's phone call. So I think
we need to talk about— We've already adjourned the meeting, so the ship's kind of
sailed. So if we need to come back
on that item. Yeah, we've already adjourned the meetings, so that ship's kind of sailed
anyway. Yeah, I don't know. That's my bad. So sorry, I should have waited.
I waited.